bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8 en ce
14 novembre à partir de 18h en direct le
tour de l'actualité locale tout de suite
les principaux titres de l'actualité les
sujets à découvrir au cours de cette
édition en images les chirurgiens et
médecins libéraux dans la rue elle ce
mercredi une manifestation devant le
ministère de la santé à paris à laquelle
ont participé des médecins de l'hôpital
privé de trappes nous expliquerons les
raisons de leur colère la dernière ligne
droite pour les candidats à la
présidence de l'ump l'élection a lieu
dimanche il faut continuer à convaincre
les militants françois fillon était ce
mardi soir à poissy jean françois copé
viendra lui samedi à saint germain en
laye le forum de coignières reprend ses
travaux de rénovation arrêté en raison
de recours y se poursuivre pour une fin
de chantier prévue en 2013 et puis c'est
aujourd'hui la journée mondiale du
diabète l'occasion pour certains de se
faire dépister cela prend quelques
secondes en france cinq cent mille
personnes seraient diabétiques sans le
savoir à nous avons sur ce plateau jean
jacques casault navette bonsoir à vous
vous êtes un peu président dans les
yvelines de l'aef des l'association
française des diabétiques nous
développons ce sujet dans un instant
comme chaque mercredi une large page
culture également avec déjà sur ce
plateau cécile coûte un bon soir lorsque
vous êtes auteur historienne et vous
avez publié un ouvrage dont nous
parlerons tout à l'heure également sur
ce plateau avec emmanuel de crépy la
maire adjointe à la culture de
versailles tout simplement car les 17 et
18 novembre se déroulera le salon
histoire de livres de lire les livres
pour apprendre l'histoire les livres qui
parle d'histoire c'est la thématique de
ce salon qui rencontre toujours un grand
succès du côté de versailles et puis
nous parlons des hip hop games à
quelques jours d'un spectacle présenté à
guyancourt loup demontis auteur
compositeur interprète au 6e rang
plateau pour la sortie d'un nouvel album
très rock et inspirée par une référence
du genre bruce springsteen gh on débute
par la politique le duel pour la
présidence de l'ump s'achèvera donc
dimanche par un vote des militants ils
seront douze mille à participer au
scrutin dans le département 12000 être
appelés aux urnes est deux candidats qui
sont engagés dans la campagne et qui ont
choisi le département des yvelines pour
organiser leur dernier mot si me jean
françois copé sera saint germain samedi
et puis françois fillon était lui dès
hier à poissy le ton monte dans cette
dernière ligne droite reportage de
catherine zola tôt et de guillaume corse
1500 militants ump beaucoup de
parlementaires d'élus locaux rassemblés
ce mardi soir à poissy pour attendre
leur favori à la présidence de l'ump
l'ancien premier ministre françois
fillon une ambiance emmenés par un
tandem david douillet député de la
circonscription et valérie pécresse
c'est un véritable homme d'état c'est
quelqu'un qui
a su diriger la france d'une main de
maître côté nicolas sarkozy pendant cinq
ans et j'ai eu cette chance d'être à ses
côtés pendant un an tant que ministre et
donc la vraie manger j'ai connu un vrai
chef voilà un chef qui sait prendre du
recul un chef qui sait analyser qui sait
écouter surtout regagné dans les urnes
dès 2014 avec françois fillon c'est
possible parce que c'est le seul qui
peut à la fois être suffisamment ferme
pour nous ramener les électeurs qui sont
partis au front national et en même
temps suffisamment républicain ouvert
serein pour nous ramener les électeurs
centristes qui sont partis voter
hollande rassembler le maître mot de
cette soirée rassemblés au sens large
françois fillon ne s'en cache pas il en
profite même pour égratigner son
adversaire jean françois copé cette
stratégie du rassemblement distinct de
jean trottoirs pas en réalité la
question de la ligne politique que vous
allez choisir et c'est normal que dans
une élection vous ayez à choisir une
ligne politique certains pensent que
l'on reverra la france en prenant tous
les virages à droite moi j'ai la
conviction qu'on l'a regagnera par la
droite par le genre et même par la con
une fin de campagne ici dans les
yvelines ce n'est pas un hasard pour
françois fillon car il l'a rappelé
pendant son discours s'il devient
président de l'ump c'est valérie
pécresse qui deviendra l secrétaire
général d'abord elle a participé d'une
façon extraordinaire à la campagne mais
surtout elle al'étoffe d'un grand
secrétaire général de l'ump dont j'ai
besoin pour rénover notre parti et pour
pouvoir si les militants me font
confiance me consacrer totalement à
porter le message de l'ump est allé
au-devant des français dernière ligne
droite donc avant l'élection jean
françois copé lui tiendra son dernier
meeting ce samedi également dans le
département à saint germain en laye il
est de son côté soutenue par henri
guaino l'ancienne plume de nicolas
sarkozy ou jean frédéric poisson lé
député de la 10e circonscription j'ai
été membre du groupe ump dans la
mandature précédente je les ai vus
diriger le groupe politique notre groupe
politique à l'assemblée nationale je les
veux diriger comme secrétaire national
de l'ump que je suis encore
notre famille politique et il a montré
dans ces deux circonstances des qualités
qui sont essentiels à mon avis pour
diriger ce genre d'organisation ce
travail là je pense jean-françois copé a
envie de le faire il a envie de le faire
d'une manière qui me convient donc pour
ces trois raisons qui me soutient les
militants ump sont donc amenés à se
prononcer ce dimanche dans les yvelines
12000 sont invités à se rendre aux urnes
et la phrase du jour elle est signée
valérie pécresse la présidente de la
fédération ump des yvelines lors du
meeting hier soir de françois fillon a
déclaré faire basculer saint quentin en
yvelines c'est notre e et défis en
jetant un regard complice en direction
de jean michel fourgous le maire
d'elancourt candidat malheureux aux
dernières législatives qui a perdu son
mandat je vous le rappelle face à benoît
hamon la députée des yvelines espèrent
voir basculer l'une des villes de sa
circonscription la 2e circonscription
c'est magny les hameaux si la droite
venait à l'emporter en 2014 et qu'aucun
changement n'est intervenu dans les six
autres communes de saint quentin en
yvelines l'agglomération changerait de
majorité rappelons que saint quentin
fait figure d'exception dans un
département toujours majoritairement à
droite on passe à la principale
information de ce 14 novembre la journée
mondiale du diabète sa création remonte
à 1991
le président dans les yvelines de
l'association française des diabétiques
et donc avec nous en plateau on va
donner quelques chiffres pour débuter
peut-être 35000 personnes qui sont
concernées par le diabète dans le
département des yvelines plus de 3
millions de personnes en france et 500
mille personnes aussi en france qui
s'ignoraient qui ignorerait la à la
maladie on peut parler d'un véritable
fléau on peut parler effectivement
bonsoir on peut parler d'un fléau alors
je voudrais simplement même précisé que
les derniers chiffres a priori porte sur
à peu près 700 mille mercis niort donc
est ce qui porterait plutôt à 3 millions
5,4 millions à l'heure actuelle le
nombre de personnes diabétiques et les
médecins le disent le répète les
associations également plus le dépistage
a lieu tout au moins de complications il
y aura par la suite vous faites vous
dépister régulièrement suivre en tout
cas c'est la question que nous avons
posée aujourd'hui dans les rues de saint
quentin en yvelines
oui oui parce que mon médecin
généraliste vais faire des plus de cent
une fois par an ou à peu près non pas du
tout je pense que j'ai pas de diabète
j'ai été déjà contrôlé et supra qui est
là dessus mais effectivement je ça
serait quelque chose de bien à faire
pour la forme tous les deux ans à un
bilan complet voilà c'est tout donc
c'est dedans
obligatoirement quand je vois le nombre
de lignes j'ai fait du diabète en plus
pendant la grossesse donc j'ai eu un
suivi juste après mais là depuis
depuis cinq ans non pas du tout non pas
du tout je pense pas donc je pense pas
serré je me fais pas dépister
régulièrement mais pour d'autres raisons
j'ai des prises de sang relativement
régulière et j'ai pas de soucis diabète
pas beaucoup mais bon si à l'occasion
d'une prise de sang évidemment je vais
contrôler mon diabète a pas du tout
c'est quelque chose que j'ai des
analyses de sang régulières pour
d'autres raisons moi je suppose qu'on le
trouverait si si j'en avais mais non
j'en ai pas mais je sais depuis peu
parce qu'on n'en parle pas mal que c'est
très grave finalement on peut devenir
aveugle on peut devenir je ne sais plus
quoi bon c'est tout c'est la journée du
diabète donc il faut se faire dépister
c'est ça
il faut se faire dépister c'est le
message et les gens en tout cas bien
assimilé ce message plus de 6 français
âgé de 40 ans et plus sont sur 10 ont
déjà réalisé un dépistage du diabète
pour savoir s'ils étaient atteints par
cette maladie c'est un sondage qui
remonte tout de même à 2010 on espère
que les chiffres sont un peu meilleures
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est suffisant
60% à peu près de la population il
faudrait que ce soit 100% il faudrait
que ce sens il faut le rendre
obligatoire le dépistage n'ont peut-être
pas parce qu'il faut quand même que ce
soit une démarche personnelle mais là à
entendre le reportage effectivement il
ya des personnes qui qui ne se font pas
ne pas suivre tous les deux ans ça ne
paraît déjà très très long comme comme
des surtout arriver à une cinquantaine
d'années il est quand même préférable de
faire un bilan annuel que ce soit pour
le diabète ou pour le reste d'ailleurs
plus de 551 millions de personnes seront
atteintes de cette maladie du diabète
d'ici 2030 comment on peut pallier à ce
phénomène alors vous avez de deux types
de diabète le diabète de type 1 et le
diabète de type 2 faut bien différencier
les deux le diabète de type 1
effectivement
à l'heure actuelle il ya des causes qui
sont plus tôt
de la défense immunitaire de mauvaises
défenses immunitaires on n'en sait pas
beaucoup plus par contre on peut
beaucoup plus s'attaquer au diabète de
type 2 et là j'entends des une émission
cet après-midi en fait je dirais ces
gens là dit yaka et le yaka c'est en
fait faire déjà faire faire une prise de
sang régulièrement pour savoir où on en
est et surtout arriver un certain âge
cinquantaine de d'avoir une activité
physique la plus importante possible
c'est l'hygiène de vie des dons et une
hygiène de vie avec une alimentation
équilibrée sur la recherche aussi on en
est où parce que actuellement sur la
région et en guérir n'ont actuellement
au jour d'aujourd'hui on en guérit pas
on soigne le diabète on peut bien en
vivre à titre personnel j'en ai un
depuis 40 ans et je vis correctement il
ya quelques petites contraintes mais je
dirais que actuellement au niveau de la
recherche à part des études qui sont
menées sur les greffes d'îlots d'îlots
de langerhans puisque les audiences sont
une partie petite partie du pancréas qui
secrète de l'insuline et sur le diabète
de type 1 cci l'eau qui ne fournissent
plus du tout d'insuline donc il faut on
a recours à des piqûres d'insuline soit
classique ou par pompe à insuline au
niveau de la recherche il ya quelques
griffes 10 lots qui sont actuellement en
cours on va continuer à évoquer ce sujet
avec vous on va se rendre à bois d'arcy
la présention une opération de dépistage
que vous avez organisé pour la pour les
fds 78 je rappelle ce chiffre en tout de
même cinq cent mille personnes qui
ignorent être porteur à voir le diabète
le dépistage est important voici ce
reportage
une piqûre sur le bout du doigt même pas
le temps de prendre sa respiration et
c'est fait martine clerc est venu tester
son taux de sucre dans le sang son
niveau de diabète parce que la dernière
fois j'avais se trouvait un taux un
petit peu élevé le matin à jeun par le
laboratoire
donc j'ai voulu recontrôler alors ça a
donné quoi ah bah c'est parfait
aujourd'hui c'est parfait 110 donc ça
doit être bon pour quelqu'un qui vient
de cas des jeunes et il ya moins de deux
heures pour sa part 5 moi aussi c'est
parfait elles ont le sourire tant mieux
en france on estime à 3 millions et demi
le nombre de diabétiques dont 500000
signoret les risques sont pourtant réels
on va avoir tous les risques
cardiovasculaires tous les risques bah
justement quand on parle de risque
cardiovasculaire et de complications ça
va forcément tous et tous les petits
vaisseaux et gros vaisseaux et donc
entraîner des problèmes que ce soit au
niveau des yeux au niveau des reins au
niveau du coeur il existe deux types de
diabète le diabète de type 1 qui touche
les enfants et les adolescents et le
diabète de type 2 qui concerne les plus
de 40 ans mais qui atteint de plus en
plus de jeunes en cause la sédentarité
et la malbouffe les conseils de
prévention sont évidents d'avoir une
activité physique
d'équilibrer ses repas s'il n'est pas
facile pour tous un vu de la conjoncture
actuelle que nous rencontrons dans la
société pour nos jeunes diabétiques
c'est avoir un équilibre puisque pour le
diabète de type 1 malheureusement nos
jeunes sont tout de suite traité par
insuline donc c'est d'adapter leur
traitement à leur vie de tous les jours
et de continuer à vivre normalement avec
une hygiène de vie le diabète est une
maladie du pancréas elle est invisible
mais il ya des signes qui doivent
prévenir comme incertaine amaigrissement
une soif importante un besoin d'uriner
et un manque d'attention pour les plus
jeunes enfants
voilà pour cette opération que vous avez
organisé quels sont les autres
opérations vous pouvez organiser tout au
long de l'année avec l'association
française des diabétiques alors tout au
long de l'année nous organisons donc dé
sensibilisation qui peuvent être des
sensibilisations sans dépistage mais
également avec dépistage donc en moyenne
nous réalisons
une dizaine de dépistage dans l'année ça
fait à peu près 1 par mois dans toutes
les villes à la foule des parts dans le
département des yvelines ce qui
représente à peu près 1200 à 1300
personnes dépistées il était question
d'une maison du diabète aussi dans le
département il était il est question
d'une maison il est toujours question
est ce que ce n'est pas vraiment
d'actualité c'est pas vraiment
d'actualité j'en parlerai pas plus parce
que c'est pas nous qui sommes ils ont
concerné par cette maison du diabète
mais c'est un regret en tout cas il n'y
ait pas plus de structures pour pour
informer on en parle forcément
aujourd'hui beaucoup puisque c'est une
journée mondiale 1 150 pays qui sont qui
sont mobilisés au delà de ça vous avez
le sentiment qu'au quotidien c'est
devenu on n'en parle pas assez alors au
quotidien on n'en parle pas assez il ya
effectivement sûrement des priorités on
essaie nous devons notre dans nos
possibilités de développer un maximum
ces sensibilisations
il faut savoir que nous sommes tous des
bénévoles et que nous avons énormément
de mal à recruter d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour lancer un appel parce que
là ça met vraiment en péril je dirais
même pour l'année prochaine la viabilité
de notre association bien que nous
soyons fédérer auprès de l'afd au niveau
national bien sûr nous sommes sans cette
fédération départementale
malgré tout dans les yvelines nous avons
extrêmement
beaucoup de difficultés déjà le
financement et puis et puis de bénévoles
a également le message est en tout cas
passé vous n'hésitez pas à nous
contacter et on se fera le relais bien à
vivre via un site internet qui existent
en af des points asso.fr il s'est
affiché pour avoir plus d'informations
c'est exact je voulais préciser que pour
les deux autres manifestations qui vont
avoir lieu très prochainement la
prochaine a lieu le 17 samedi 17
novembre à chambourcy magasins carrefour
organisé par la cpam des yvelines donc
nous sommes partenaires est également au
centre social andré malraux le 22
novembre également avec la cepam puisque
nous sommes partenaires de la cepl jean
jacques casault met merci d'être venu
sur ce plateau excusez moi pour avoir
écorché votre prénom avoir conclu à cet
entretien sur une mauvaise note merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau pour à
l'occasion de cette journée mondiale du
diabète avec cette importance de se
faire dépister cinq cent mille personnes
qui s'ignorent 700000 même vous nous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure donc les
opérations sont menées vous avez rappelé
les prochaines dates merci à vous on va
parler mercier de culture à présent avec
les deux autres invités qui sont sur ce
plateau avec un salon qui va s'ouvrir du
côté de versailles